[Music]
[Applause]
flashpoint oh that's rude hey everybody
so we have to talk about all the big
news that dropped about Justice League
all the DC movies that are coming up so
I'll try to explain what's true what's
false
and where this is all coming from so
right off the bat I'll say it's all good
news it's all based on the success that
they've had recently they're just
leaning into the things that have been
successful which makes sense so if
you're finding me for the first time I
do DC videos every week the flash is
coming up real soon be sure to subscribe
to get everything
there is flash ring giveaway stuff that
I'll explain at the end of the video but
the big thing that everybody is quoting
from is this vulture article where did
this person win and talk to Geoff Johns
and basically did a history of the DC
ehue so like going all the way back to
2008-2009 Christopher Nolan was slowly
leaving in Zack Snyder was getting ready
to come in to start doing Man of Steel
and they announced like their giant
movie slate if you remember that a
couple years ago it was all right before
that happened right before geoff johns
was elevated to his current position
before Diane Nelson was hired before DC
Comics became DC entertainment like the
big media company that was pushing out a
whole bunch of TV shows and movies so
we'll talk about that in a second but
the end result like the important thing
is that what they're doing now is that
they're just playing it more like the
Bond films when it comes to continuity
and that things will be connected
there's still be a DC Universe the
immediate example would be Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman is connected to Justice
League and Batman V Superman but they
didn't shoehorn a whole bunch of stuff
in there's a truck from Wayne
Enterprises there's the picture from
Batman V Superman so that's sort of the
connective tissue that helps you place
it in a timeline Oh
okay this scene is happening right after
Batman V Superman but before Justice
League then the rest of the movie is off
doing its own thing they don't reference
the Justice League at all during most of
the Wonder Woman movie at the tail end
she just talks about what she's going to
do going forward there's no post-credit
scene or anything like that so it just
sounds like they're gonna allow the
movies for each of the characters like
the Aquaman movie to work like that and
that's how it'll be connected to the DC
EU in the other funny detail that came
out of the interview is the DC extended
universe is not a term that they use
inside DC entertainment or Warner
Brothers that was something that
somebody who wrote an article about it
early on when they announced their
cinematic universe that everybody
started quoting it just assumed that it
was an official term they haven't
actually said what they really call it
but I'm assuming that it's like the
Justice League universe because that's
really the film's where you'll see all
the characters pop up together
they also said going forward they would
continue to do those heavy mythology
films where everybody crosses over so
they're just making room for films to
fit into the Cinematic Universe in a
guardians of the galaxy type way like
guardians of the galaxy is connected to
the Marvel Universe but how much do you
see them reference this stuff that's
happening on earth during those movies
not a whole lot like you don't see Iron
Man pop up during guardians of the
galaxy so before all this happened the
last couple of years that was not the
plan the plan was to do a Marvel style
crossover where all the films connect in
a really big way so there's a whole
bunch of business stuff that happened
behind the scenes that I'll explain in a
second that gets a little more
complicated but one of the cool things
to come out of this interview is that
you'll see a lot of the creative
problems that they had were mostly due
to the bureaucracy behind the scenes
from the pre-existing regime which have
all since either been fired or moved on
to other companies they confirm the
Wonder Woman was the first film that the
new regime was actually able to do real
work on so no surprise that it is one of
the most successful DC movies of all
time not just of the modern era but it's
actually stacking up against some of the
classic big blockbuster Batman films so
that just lets you know that things are
moving in the right direction but a lot
of you will probably understand what I
say the wheels of bureaucracy
seat turned slowly so you find that a
lot of the real problems that have been
caused the last couple of years like
pretty much every bad thing that's
happened that you've been really upset
by has been caused mostly by the
Hollywood bureaucracy that existed
before Geoff Johns Diane Nelson like all
the new people came in so the history of
all this is really fascinating sort of
the history of the DCE you just to
explain that a little bit what happened
is is in 2009 you have the old regime at
Warner Brothers that sees Marvel getting
ready to blow it up with Iron Man in
their big first phase they got two
Avengers they were so far ahead of every
other movie studio that people were like
oh my god we need our Cinematic Universe
you see people doing it with other
versions of movies not just comic book
movies but because Warner Brothers had
access to all the DC IP but they're like
okay we need to start using these DC
characters we need our Cinematic
Universe so a bunch of business people
up at the top like the CEO the president
of their film division who has since
been fired announced like 13 films like
these are all the films we're gonna do
these are the dates they're gonna come
out we'll figure out the creative later
then after they made all those decisions
they hired Diane Nelson to sort of
oversee the development of all their
film and TV IP they're like okay we have
all these characters let's start making
some money on them the way that Marvel
is making money on their characters
Diane Nelson hired geoff johns to be
sort of the comic book guy to help the
movie people who did not read comics so
before this all happened
the people that made the comic book
movies like the batman movies they were
not really comic-book people
Kevin Smith actually talks about his
Superman script when he went to meet on
it it was sometime in the mid-2000s he
said that he was talking to the film
people at Warner Brothers and one of
them was like don't talk to them about
comic books they won't take you
seriously and Kevin Smith basically said
that all those people that were in
charge of making the DC movies at Warner
Brothers didn't care about comic books
at all they're like we know how to make
a movie we don't need to read those so
the problem that they have is that they
have Christopher Nolan making the Dark
Knight trilogy with complete creative
control he's an amazing filmmaker but
once he leaves basically all their good
comic book people inside the movie
studio system are gone they don't give a
[ __ ]
about what the people that write the
really awesome comic book stories are
doing so they don't pay attention to
them they want somebody new to come in
so they go to Christopher Nolan and they
say we want to make a Superman movie so
Christopher Nolan suggests that they
hire Zack Snyder so regardless of how
you feel about Man of Steel Batman V
Superman you may have heard some quotes
from the interview about how they
weren't super happy with elements from
those scripts but the good thing about
Zack Snyder is that he has like a really
specific vision he's worked on comic
book movies of that scale before
and even though Watchmen was really
critically divisive at the time he was
just the strongest candidate that they
had so they brought him on
they wanted their cinematic universe so
they put him in charge of it so they're
like okay these are the movies that you
have to make you have to put these
characters in these to build up to
Justice League so you basically just
wind up with a situation where a bunch
of people that don't care about comic
books try to make a cinematic universe
and then they finally start listening to
the comic book people and slowly start
making the changes they need to make the
people that we're getting in the way of
that have been fired have since moved on
they brought in new people but because
there's hundreds of millions of dollars
in all this the wheels turn really
slowly so the films that you see coming
up like Aquaman for instance will be
fantastic but it'll work a little bit
more like Wonder Woman the way it fits
into continuity so hopefully that
explains what the big changes are it's
not as bad as it sounds like people say
that they're abandoning the DCE you
that's not exactly what they're doing
they're just playing it a little faster
and looser with the way they shoehorn
stuff into other people's movies so you
will also notice that the last couple of
Marvel movies have also done the same
thing there's a less crossover than you
saw during phase one and phase two but
Kevin Feige has also said that hey you
know we don't actually have to jam a
bunch of other people's stuff into these
movies we can let them be their own
thing people understand that it's a
connected universe so at the end of the
day I think it'll just lead to much
better movies and you'll have fewer
business people making creative
decisions when you should actually just
rely on the comic book people who
already know what they're doing working
with really good filmmakers which is
what they're doing right now so I
realized that that's sort of like the
Cliff's Notes version
feel free to ask any questions you have
about how the
movies are gonna work or how everything
is going to go down the next couple of
years in the comments and I'll try to
answer that so they announced the
flashpoint movie and suddenly it all
makes sense it's their opportunity to
reconfigure the things that they want to
change and they can still have their
continuity and it'll make sense from a
logic perspective and yes they can
totally do Jeffrey Dean Morgan
Thomas Wayne it just depends on which
version of flashpoint they're going to
do the only real problem I think the DC
movies have right now is just
communication there's no Kevin Feige
figure or a James Gunn filmmaker person
who comes out and just flat-out tells
people this isn't true or they're just
super connected to everyone James Gunn
is on Facebook like every day telling
fans no this is bullcrap this is true
this is the stuff I'm working on he'll
drop teasers about guardians 3 they just
don't have a lot of filmmakers that are
that connected and well received by the
fans there's just a lot of controversy
going on in the background and that's
mostly due to their communication I
think that Matt Reeves will actually be
a good Batman filmmaker because he
actually is pretty open with people he
said a lot about what he's doing with
his Batman franchise even though it's
only in pre-production they're still
writing the scripts right now but there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner Zach Hartley please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so just a reminder flash is
coming up there'll be some new stuff
next week you can click here for brand
new flash and you can click here for
brand new Rick and Morty thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you